because I just men and women were
opposite so the man's been battling all
day battling battling verbally
physically and going against it now he
wants to get home and just feel woosa
the woman may have been
like suppressing suppressing all day
suppressing suppressing so for me I've
been all day trying to not be that angry
black girl now I'll come home I can Dash
my bag take off my wig do you know what
this woman said to me and I had to smile
between my teeth and he's probably
thinking Lord God no that's well
but we're opposite so that's maybe why
it could Clash yeah no I've like talked
to guys about this and they just need
like a decompression time like they need
like 30 minutes straight in the door
yeah like to just and and honestly if we
can I think they preferred if we go to
our friends about like about little
stuff but like big problems if it comes
back to the trust and the decision
making well I'm saying most of my
friends are female which is highly yeah
but I want to trust a man right now it's
going to be mine well I'm saying like
Okay does he really need to know that
Tracy at work was giving you the side
act no oh my God
I need a man to tell me okay I'm
basically going to my mind saying babe
what should I do should I punch her
should I chill obviously sometimes I do
know the better option but I just need
your support so I I do think guys you
guys could correct me but if you say
like how do I address this situation I
think guys are problem solvers so
they'll help you fix it but I think as
women we don't want them to fit like we
just want them to listen yeah juice so
so it confuses them because we'll be
like yeah this [ __ ] at work she did
this this and this and then he said okay
this is how you solve it and we're like
well no I just like she still did this
this year why can't you agreeing with me
I'll give you an example my dad like
I'll say oh this person I did this this
and he'll be like well just don't deal
with them anymore yeah excuse me
like literally what you're saying but I
like so what Pearl's saying is like us
as men we want to listen to your
problems but we don't really want to
listen to your problems so we'll get
that so so we're waiting to offload but
after a certain amount of time we're
gonna we're gonna want to give you a
strategy to fix this boss right but you
don't want to actually fix it you just
want to moan about your boss so at that
point it's kind of like
you have to go to your girls after that
because all you really want to do is
just talk right but us as men we don't
want to spend an hour talking about the
same thing we want to get to an end of
it and we want you to resolve it but
you're going to go back to your butt and
say to me the next oh you know what I
like my boss again I'll give you one
example there's some men that will
ostracize a woman from their friends
their family get them to themselves not
saying there's some that's what I said
some get them to themselves
um some men can do this without being
abusive they could just be selfish I
love my woman cool like you do you baby
um some people like them obsessed some
people don't and like now you've
ostracized her you're actually her
number one go-to and now you're telling
me I just want peace after you ostrich
no I don't think those types of men I
think okay if you're going to talk about
that I don't think those types of men do
you told me Tracy's a hoe you told me my
mommy
that's kind of on the woman like
sometimes I think like women kind of
like that drama because it's like you
put up with it if if you you picked them
you don't have to stay like why'd you
let him ostracize you know and I've been
I've been in a Sim I've been in a
similar situation but I'll take
accountability I think I did that I
think now I'm older I can see the
ostracization coming in but being for
younger females you don't have that much
perception on life yeah I think though
like sometimes guys just want to get you
away from your whole friends
that I'm talking about come on guys
we're not but then your mama
guys that make you feel like you
shouldn't be talking to anyone else but
me you know someone's very like
obsessive like almost obsessive like
they don't need to be the only thing
when I've made you not my only thing
exactly you see how you said the same I
don't think you should do that like he
shouldn't do that yeah but you see how
he said the same demographic of women
that um would rub a Nick are the same
that thing I'm just giving that example
like a lot of guys not all but a lot of
of guys that will be like
a lot of guys that would find uh like oh
she's just bad telling me stuff she's
always coming to me telling me about her
this and that and this most of those
guys have ostracized that woman and now
they're asking for peace or some men
don't know how to create a peaceful
environment for the female and then
expect peace oh I just want peace no you
want someone to shut the [ __ ] up wait
did this did this happen to you yeah
yeah
it sounds really specific probably
somewhere subconsciously I'm not gonna
lie maybe maybe there's a little Vim or
maybe I just it may be a little bit of
me in a little bit of an observation
because I love to observe I just think
like you pick who you're in a
relationship with and I think there's
there's a group of girls that like to be
controlled like they just oh no it kind
of happened to me it almost did like I I
was like hold on why don't I check my
mom's okay like I had to ask myself was
it the D a little bit was it the energy
so juice but then I realized he actually
cursed everybody out of my life
everybody like my friend he had a
problem with this person had a problem
with and obviously but it's a red flag
so so going on so so going off me as a
man I have no problem in in calling out
a man's ball or red flags or anything
like that like I would it's not
something I would have my sister
entertain it's not something I recommend
it's not something I recommend any woman
to do
um so if a man is trying to ostracize
you trying to alienate you from your
friends yeah these are these are all
types of controlling behaviors so yeah
it's not something I will support but a
man trying to get you away from that
whole friend Tracy no that's that's a
good man I'm being real
he's a good man
anyone's name who's Tracy is like excuse
me sorry trains you're a good girl
I feel like most of this leads back to
communication they're like if you want
to vent to the guy that you're with just
ask him there's nothing wrong with that
same with like your friends like say if
I want to vent to my friends I'd be like
can I open up to you right now are you
in the right mind frame to hear from me
type thing there's nothing wrong asking
for communication the guy will let you
know and if it's not today then it might
be tomorrow or it might be the day after
like yeah it's kind of going back to
reading the room and being socially
aware like you can perform and know that
your partner is like he's he's not with
it so yeah would you would you um any of
your girls would you would you mind if
your man cried to you okay to you cry
yeah
I've had my partner of like nine years
cry I'll be like yes my babies
yes my baby needs meat or your partner
of nine years no no no no no who said
that you said that yeah I've had I've
been with someone for nine years okay so
ever a question um you're not with him
anymore no I'm not who broke up with who
I I'll say I broke up with him you
should have cried every time
I know it's I know it's like every girl
that it's again it's not you yeah
statistically proven no no I'm just
anecdotal no stats I've had girl after
girl come on my podcast and everyone
that says their boyfriend cried to them
I have a second question who broke up
with you it's always them but it always
depends on what wait he didn't cry in a
way of like he was actually being
emotional I was telling him this thing I
don't know what you're doing right now I
gave him some facts but the situation
happens and I presented him with facts
and I was like this is what's going on
as your business and he the only way he
knew how to communicate was to break
down as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible